promesas de paz el gobierno del
presidente Gustavo Petro comienza desde
este jueves un cese de hostilidades
junto con la guerrilla del eln con la
cual ya ha celebrado tres rondas de
conversaciones en un proceso de paz que
dio inicio a finales del año pasado Sin
embargo varias acciones violentas del
eln han marcado estas negociaciones la
última de ellas conocida Este miércoles
con el secuestro de una Sargento y sus
dos hijos de seis y ocho años uno de
ellos En condición de autismo en el
departamento de arauca fronterizo con
Venezuela Espero que el eln no solo
reconozca El secuestro sino que haga las
acciones inmediatas para liberar a esta
señora y a sus hijos y
tratemos de conectarnos con un país que
está diciendo por favor ya no más locura
de guerra lo que queremos es Paz pese al
secuestro el presidente mantiene su plan
original acordado en junio en la Habana
con lln este 6 de Julio comienza el cese
de hostilidades Y a partir del 3 de
agosto entraría en vigor un alto el
fuego literal con los protocolos
necesarios y los mecanismos de
verificación pero para algunos expertos
la pregunta gira en torno a la voluntad
de paz del eln son unos lunares que no
favorecen para nada el inicio y el César
fuego entre el eln y las fuerzas
militares también pues parte de el
inicio de este css pues sería bien
acompañado en este caso de la liberación
de las armas y sus dos hijos y también
pues la suspensión de acciones militares
por parte de esta estructura Armada
ilegal desde la oposición del centro
democrático calificaron de farsa este
proceso con el eln se estima que esta
guerrilla cuenta con unos 4.000
efectivos y poner fin a la lucha armada
con ellos hace parte de la promesa de la
paz total bandera del presidente Petro